ich hatte ab dem ersten januar
nicht nur das familienministerium und
die spitzenkandidatur
ich habe auch das umweltministerium
geschäftsführend mit übernommen und ich
habe diese aufgabe sehr ernst genommen
und es war zu viel
das hat uns als familie über die grenze
gebracht ich habe danach weder für die
grünen die koalitionsverhandlungen
gemacht
aber mein mann war
sehr stark
auch belastet
und es war wirklich an einem punkt zum
ersten mal für uns als familie
wo wir urlaub gebraucht haben weil mein
mann nicht mehr konnte und es war für
mich eine sehr schwere abwägung die ich
mir auch nicht leicht gemacht hatte
zwischen meiner an verantwortung als
ministerin und
der verantwortung
als mutter
mit vier kindern
die noch klein sind und die in der
korona pandemie
nicht gut durch diese pandemie gekommen
sind und deshalb
haben wir uns als familie entschieden
am sonntag den 25
juli in urlaub zu fahren das war zehn
tage nach der flutkatastrophe und
das war
ein fehler dass wir
auch so langen urlaub gefahren sind und
dass wir in urlaub gefahren sind
und ich bitte
für diesen fehler
um entschuldigung
ich habe
unmittelbar am morgen nach der
schrecklichen flut nacht sofort einen
krisenstab einberufen
für den wiederaufbau der
trinkwasserversorgung
die wiederherstellung deckel von
kläranlagen der wiederaufbau der
energieversorgung
und dann auch für die beseitigung von
schutt und abfall ich habe in den tagen
nach
der katastrophe ein 20 millionen euro
sofortprogramm für die kommunen auf den
weg gebracht
und ich bin dann zehn tage später aus
den gründen die ich gerade geschildert
habe
weil ich mich in der abwägung
entschieden hatte dass ich an diesem
punkt für meine familie da sein muss in
urlaub gefahren
ich war während des urlaubs immer
erreichbar ich habe telefonate geführt
und ich habe mich immer informiert und
wenn es irgendeinen anlass gegeben hätte
den urlaub abzubrechen dann hätte ich
das auch sofort getan
ich habe
gestern als ich auf polen reise war als
bundesministerin
sehr kurzfristig von der anfrage
der bild am sonntag erfahren wir haben
dann im bus in polen zwischen zwei
terminen die anfrage
besprochen
und erörtert und ich habe telefoniert
ich hatte die info dass
in meinem kalender während meines
urlaubs
die kabinettssitzung stehen und deswegen
haben wir das an gegeben und ich habe
das auch frei gegeben ich bin gestern
abend von der polen reise
zurückgekommen
ich war mir unsicher ich habe das heute
in den protokollen
der kabinettssitzung prüfen lassen
ich habe nicht aus meinem urlaub heraus
an den kabinettssitzung teilgenommen
aber ich möchte betonen dass ich die
ganze zeit erreichbar war ich habe mit
dem ministerpräsidenten gesprochen ich
habe mit meinen staatssekretären
gesprochen telefoniert ich habe
natürlich auch bei in den mails
und es ist auch zutreffend dass ich
meinen urlaub unterbrochen habe um für
einen tag zurück ins tal zu kommen
jetzt überlege ich noch aber irgendwas
zu müssen noch irgendwie abfinden
ich
möchte mich
für die fehler
ausdrücklich
entschuldigen
danke
soweit also bundesfamilienministerin
anne spiegel die wirklich sichtlich
angefasst sehr emotional war den tränen
nahe und bei mir im studio ralf schuler
ralf wir haben gerade das statement
gesehen eine sichtlich überforderte
familienministerin sie hat gesagt es war
zu viel sie war überfordert wie schätzt
du das ganze ein ja es geht natürlich
nur wenn man das sieht es ist die
personifizierte überforderung
ich habe am freitagnachmittag bei dem
ministerium angefragt gefragt in mainz
und in berlin also nicht gestern wie sie
das eben gezeigt hat und dann hieß es
immer am montag werde sie sich äußern
das ist also eine sehr ungute geschichte
und man kann als mit familienministerin
als bundesministerin kann man auch so
einen auftritt nicht hinlegen wie jetzt
eben
man bei allem verständnis für die
gigantische leistung die bundesminister
und erst recht kanzlei auf sich nehmen
wir haben lange zeit darüber berichtet
es geht nicht dass man dann falsche
angaben schriftlich übermittelt und das
hat sie in dem statement was wir dann
gestern bekommen haben steht ganz klar
drin teilnahme an kabinettssitzungen bei
aller liebe dann haben entweder die
mitarbeiter etwas falsch gemacht und sie
hat sich nicht richtig geführt
solche auftritte kann man einmal bringen
und dann eigentlich nie wieder also es
tut mir wirklich leid
offensichtlich gibt es da auch familiäre
probleme aber gerade im angesicht der
flutopfer
funktioniert das so nicht und wenn man
ein jahr später nicht in der lage ist
von einer polenreise aus eine einfache
anfrage wann war die ministerinnen
urlaub korrekt zu beantworten
sorry dann fehlt mir jedes verständnis
es ist schluss dass sowas kann man nicht
hinnehmen dass wissen glaube ich auch
die spitzen grünen das ganze eben
passiert nachdem die bild am sonntag
heute darüber berichtet hat dass die
ministerin vier wochen im urlaub war und
wir haben vor der sendung darüber
gerätselt 21 uhr am sonntagabend
eigentlich kann das nur bedeuten dass
alle spiegel jetzt zurücktritt das hat
sie nicht gesagt ist das für dich
konsequent hätte sie es tun sollen es
wäre konsequent gewesen also wenn man
seine eigenen kräfte realistisch
einschätzt und einen solchen auftritt
hinlegt sie hat auch schon nach dem
untersuchungsausschuss in mainz einen
sichtlich an gefassten
auftritt hingelegt dann muss man sich
eingestehen dass man diesem amt nicht
gewachsen ist das ist ganz einfach so
sie war in der nacht 14 15 juli als die
flut über das aartal hinein brach war
sie über stunden nicht erreichbar
das war einfach eine katastrophe
es gab dann hinterher ein sms wechsel wo
es darum ging wie ihr image in der
öffentlichkeit dargestellt wird das ist
hoch peinlich
alles geschenkt wenn man dann aber vier
wochen welche arbeitnehmer fährt vier
wochen in den urlaub
sich von der bildfläche verabschiedet
und ein jahr später eigentlich noch
immer nicht in der lage ist das ganze so
rational zu schildern und aufzuarbeiten
wie es nötig wäre wenn man denn noch
eine zweite chance bekommen möchte dann
fehlt mir langsam wirklich jedes
verständnis und ich glaube auch nicht
dass die grünen gut beraten sind eine
ministerin in dieser angeschlagenen form
weiter im amt zu belassen das problem
der grünen besteht darin dass sie eine
sehr strenge quotierung haben und sie
dringend wieder eine frau brauchen und
sie muss vom linken flügel kommen da
gibt's personalnöte
alles gut und schön aber das sind die
probleme der grünen wir als land als
bürger haben glaube ich ein recht darauf
dass jemand tatkräftig und einsatzfähig
in diesem amt ist und das ist frau
spiegel aus meiner sicht ganz klar nicht
aus deiner sicht ich möchte gerne einmal
christoph ploß zu unseren die runde in
der runde begrüßen von der hamburger cdu
schöner sie sich heute abend noch die
zeit genommen haben herr plus auch an
sie die frage hätte frau spiegel jetzt
konsequenter handeln müssen hätte sie
ihren rücktritt erklären sollen
diese frage kann ich mit einem ganz
klaren ja beantworten als ich vorhin die
meldung bekam das ist eine
pressekonferenz von frau spiegel noch
heute abend geben soll da bin ich wie
wahrscheinlich alle anderen die die
meldung gehört haben davon ausgegangen
dass frau spiegel ihren rücktritt
erklärt gerade auch weil die grünen ja
bei anderen politikern immer genau diese
maßstäbe angelegt haben die haben gesagt
wenn jemand in so einer krise in den
urlaub fährt und auch seine pflichten
vernachlässigt dann muss er oder da muss
sie zurücktreten das haben die grünen im
nordrhein-westfälischen ministern
gefordert und daher kann ich überhaupt
nicht nachvollziehen dass sie an sich
nicht diese maßstäbe anlegen und wir
reden ja hier auch nicht über ein urlaub
der neun oder zehn tage ging sondern
vier wochen urlaub und an vierwöchigen
urlaub hat glaube ich kein arbeitnehmer
in deutschland also allein deswegen
müsste frau spiegel noch heute abend
zurücktreten jetzt haben wir das
statement gesehen sie haben sicherlich
auch verfolgt die frau frau spiegel war
unfassbar emotional sie war den tränen
nah sie hat sogar
nach worten gerungen hat von
überforderung gesprochen sich auch
mehrfach dafür entschuldigt jetzt kann
man natürlich auch sagen sie hat sich
entschuldigt wenige politiker gestehen
sich heute noch fehler ein sollte man
das nicht vielleicht auch einfach
wertschätzen ist das vielleicht auch
einfach ein zeichen von menschlichkeit
natürlich ist das ein erster schritt
wenn frau spiegel erkannt hat dass sie
daran sehr großen fehler gemacht hat nur
haben diesen fehler auch in nordrhein
westfalen eine ministerin wie frauen es
an geräumt und die grünen haben trotzdem
den rücktritt gefordert wenn sie diese
maßstäbe an ihre eigenen parteifreunde
anlegen dann müsste jetzt raus spiegel
zurücktreten und hinzu kommt noch ein
punkt das hat die pressekonferenz eben
aus meiner sicht auch gezeigt dass frau
spiegel in diesem amt wirklich heillos
überfordert ist raus spiegel ist den
aufgaben nicht gewachsen und wir können
in dieser krisenzeit keine minister im
kabinett erlauben die den aufgaben nicht
gewachsen sind zumal frau spiegel ja
nicht die einzige ministerin ist frau
lambrecht kann man denn frau feser und
noch einige andere die auf ihren
aufgaben nicht gewachsen sind und
deswegen ist diese bundesregierung im
moment international eine schande für
deutschland und innerhalb deutschlands
eine stellt sie eine große belastung für
die bevölkerung dar
also mir tut es sehr leid für die
familie von frau spiegel aber man muss
ganz klar sagen die überforderung ist
leider auch in den ersten amtstagen als
bundesministerin zu spüren gewesen sie
hat es bis letzte woche nicht geschafft
dem ausschuss ihre auf ihre projekte
liste vorzulegen das gehört sich
eigentlich für einen minister dass er
den zuständigen bundestagsausschuss sagt
was er vorhat in der letzten woche gab
es dann endlich den auftritt
ursprünglich war verschoben worden bei
frau spiegel zum frauen gipfel der
vereinten nationen nach new york fliegen
wollte statt in den ausschuss zu kommen
da ist selbstprofilierung offensichtlich
deutliche im vorrang vor dem souveränen
und dem parlament und letzte woche war
dann sehr viel von der freien wahl der
geschlechter die rede im ausschuss von
der abschaffung § 209 10 a und dem
neubau der neufassung des transsexuellen
gesetzes in dieser historischen
situation haben die flüchtlinge aus der
ukraine die absolute priorität auch der
familienministerin und dann kann man
nicht verstehen warum sie mit allen
möglichen identität projekten der
koalition da kommt aber viel zu spät
natürlich alle anderen minister haben
längst präsentiert und das ist auch die
fachliche performance die ihr sehr zu
wünschen übrig lässt
ja bloß eine abschließende frage noch
der rücktritt der ist jetzt nicht
erfolgt wie sollte die partei selbst
damit umgehen wird es jetzt eine
reaktion der grünen geben sollte dass
eine geben
wir merken ja nicht nur bei dieser
affäre sondern auch schon seit vier
jahren dass die grünen immer wieder eine
doppelmoral an den tag legen und die
legen eine andere person und an andere
parteien maßstäbe an die augenscheinlich
nicht für die grünen gelten sollen und
wenn die grüne glaubwürdigkeit zurück
erlangen wollen dann müssten sie den
rücktritt von frau spiegel einfordern
ansonsten muss man sagen ist den grünen
der moralische kompass abhanden gekommen
weil frau hallen es daran die grünen
rücktritt wäre ein neunter urlaub und
wenn eine familienministerin von den
grünen vier wochen urlaub macht dann
soll es kein rücktritt geben dafür hat
niemand im land verständnis und deswegen
müssen die grünen jetzt handeln ganz
herzlichen dank an sie christoph ploß
und auch an der schule für die
einschätzung ja ein spannender abend
geht so gesehen zu ende und liebe
zuschauer vielen dank dass sie mit dabei
waren und ich wünsche ihnen noch einen
schönen abend